hello everyone welcome to my vlogging
day I would just want to say a big thank
you so much for all of the warm
congratulations and and and warm and
happy wishes in response to my pregnancy
announcement video it really means so
much to me and also I'm so happy to hear
that it may have given some of you a
little bit of hope if you are also
struggling with infertility and that
really is my goal in in talking about
this because it's just something that's
that's not talked about enough so I'm
really happy to hear that that may have
given somebody out there a little
glimmer of hope for their rainbow baby
today we are going to do a little Q&A I
asked you all in the comment section of
my video and also in my Instagram to
comment any questions that you had about
IVF infertility pregnancy this baby etc
and you came back with so many great
questions I didn't even know where to
start but I thought you know it's
probably best if I split this into two
videos because otherwise it's going to
be excessively long and and hard to keep
track of so today we're gonna talk
mainly about infertility and IVF and the
questions that you've had around that
and then in maybe a couple weeks we'll
have another video that comes out that's
focusing more on pregnancy this
particular baby and other kind of
miscellaneous questions like that now
before we get started of course my
general disclaimer that anything you're
about to see or hear in this video is
for educational and entertainment
purposes only and I am absolutely not
prescribing anything for anybody because
everybody's case is different I really
just am trying to share my experience
and what I've learned through my journey
in infertility and trying to conceive
now on that note well let's get to our
first question okay so number one what
is your infertility diagnosis so it's
technically PCOS or polycystic ovary
syndrome and I have an amazing video all
about PCOS that I will leave a link to
in the description below but I don't
really fit the traditional mold of a
PCOS patient and that I really only fit
some of the criteria mainly that I don't
ovulate and I have slightly polycystic
over
and I'm talking like one or two or three
points over the threshold of what is
considered normal so my main actual
issue and it came to trying to conceive
at least via IVF was that my uterine
lining was not thickening and that my
baseline estrogen was very low which was
making it hard for my uterine lining to
thicken so your uterine lining if you
remember back in sex education class
from grade seven is what sheds when you
have a period each month and that's why
I wasn't getting a period and I wasn't
ovulating but that lining is really
important for the embryo to kind of bury
into and snuggle into and that's what
keeps it kind of in place for
implantation and for a successful
pregnancy so that was not happening for
me and we didn't know why exactly but I
did transfer to another doctor for this
last cycle which was the cycle that
eventually got me pregnant and that was
really amazing and my doctor suggested
very gently that you know we don't know
why your uterine lining isn't thickening
or why you're not responding to estrogen
but we also do see sometimes that some
women do respond to prolonged use of the
birth control pill and I was on the pill
for thirteen years of my life by
you know seeing this kind of suppressed
estrogen over even after you come off
and difficulty thickening the uterine
lining so maybe that's what's going on
so you may say that I had something
closer to something like post pill PCOS
or post Pillowman area but we really
don't have a whole lot of research on
that that's just something that you know
I've read about it's kind of like a like
a subset of PCOS which is a little bit
more of an umbrella term so to speak but
if you want to hear more about the
research that we do have on the birth
control pill and future fertility I can
do a whole other video on this that was
one of the questions that you guys had
for me is does the pill affect fertility
I want to know the truth that was what
somebody said and that's gonna require a
whole investigative video on itself so
if you're into
not leave me a comment below and I can
whip that up for you I'll dive deep into
the research but like I said it's
controversial and and we don't have a
whole lot of research on this post pill
amenorrhea or post pill PCOS okay next
question
did you know you're going to have
trouble conceiving and did you do
anything else before moving on to IVF
okay so I mean once upon a time when I
was a teenager I mean weren't we all
just like terrified of getting pregnant
and you thought that you only had to
have sex once and automatically you're
gonna get pregnant even if you were on
the pill and using a condom right it's
so much harder than that of course it's
easier when you're young but still I
went off the pill when this was several
years ago in like in July for example
after I got when I got married then
October came around still didn't have a
period at that point I spoke to my
daughter and I was like hmm I would like
to start to try to have a baby I don't
have a period yet from being on the pill
for so long what's going on and she said
you know some women that can take
several more months to get your period
back it could take six months or so so
just wait it out but something in my gut
was just telling me that something was
wrong that's that something was amiss so
I got a referral to a private fertility
clinic in my city Toronto and that's
where they did a workup and they
diagnosed me with PCOS so the first line
of treatment was to put me on metformin
which is a traditional drug use for
blood sugar management in people with
type 2 diabetes and so the unfortunate
thing was because my blood Sugar's it
was kind of a silly thing to put me on
and I knew that as a dietician but I did
it anyway because that's what the doctor
said but in my mind I'm thinking my
blood Sugar's are perfect like they are
not high they do not need to be managed
so the metformin actually just made me
have like a ton of blood sugar lows in
the night I wake up sweating and like
starving it was like horrible it was
just a bad experience and that went on
for months of me being on this drug
before it kind of like normalized so
tried that
see that did not bring on a period or
ovulation then they put me on a drug
called letrozole I did like five cycles
of letras all of like just continuingly
like increasing the doses and adding in
other adjuncts to the mix in an effort
to get me to ovulate never ovulated so
at that point my doctor was like you're
not ovulating so we really can't do I
you I you're not a good candidate for IU
I so we had to decide to either just
like wait it out or go straight to IVF
and I didn't I didn't want to waste any
time not knowing what was in store for
me in my life and unfortunately way this
fertility stuff works is like every
month matters right like we just get
older as women and it gets more
challenging so I didn't want to waste
any time so we just jumped right in to
IVF and we started that process in like
April so it went from like July and then
by April we were starting our drugs to
prepare for our IVF egg retrieval how
old were you when you first tried to
conceive your first child okay so I was
28 when I got married and went off the
pill I was 29 when I got pregnant so I
did the I'd started the IVF process I
guess at 29 got pregnant shortly after I
was 30 when I had my first child
now this round I'm a little bit older so
I was almost 30 - I was snuck in there
31 when I got pregnant when I got the
early news I think I was like right
around my birthday so I was like 31 32
and I'll be 32 having this baby in
August so still relatively young I mean
you're not considered a higher risk
until you're 35 and I I don't want women
out there to be freaking out because
they're almost 35 or they're 35 or older
like there are lots of women having
babies without trouble when they're 35
but we just know statistically of course
that some of the risk factors do go up
so it's just something to think about
okay what is the worst part about IVF
um so I feel like most people would
think I'm going to say either like the
needles or the money neither which are
fun especially I mean it's all it's none
of its fun the drugs the hormones how
you feel physically but I would say for
me it was the anxiety and the feeling of
like lack of control in especially
during a process where you seemingly are
controlling for almost everything it's
not just like you know you're your
normal natural cycle where you just you
have sex and maybe you'll get pregnant
that that month and you you know you're
making love like no this is a science
folks I'm taking drugs and injections at
a very specific time of a very specific
day for months so yeah like just imagine
for a second having to spend one to two
hours every morning depending on how
busy the clinic was that day in the
waiting room women you know everyone's
got their eyes down nobody wants to make
eye contact everyone feels ashamed or
just like scared and nervous and anxious
and then only to go home and literally
like wait by the phone like twiddling
your thumbs like please call me please
call me until like 3:00 p.m. that day
for the nurse to call you and to tell
you if things are looking good or if
things are looking bad so it was like
really emotionally draining and
exhausting and yeah like there's there's
a reason I didn't sleep very much this
past year so yeah for me it was it was
just the it was the emotional toll that
it took on my life all right next
question are you going to do genetic
testing yes actually we did we did a lot
of genetic testing so we my husband and
I before we even started to try to have
a baby we both had our I don't know like
our full genome tested
and then like kind of they tested it
against each other to see if we were at
risk for having children with any kind
of disabilities or disadvantages and
things like that that all came out
perfectly fine especially because my
husband's Ashkenazi Jewish which we know
that there are some higher risk factors
for Ashkenazi Jews and I am Caucasian I
guess British ancestry and as the
journalist says geneticist says I kind
of like wiped out a lot of the risk
factors with being different races
basically so yeah that that we did that
was fine
then we also PGS tested our our embryo
so it's called like pre genetic
screening so they biopsy the embryo and
then freeze it and then they test that
little piece of the embryo for certain
higher risk factors for certain genetic
diseases but also it's it's mainly to
see if that embryo is genetically
competent because oftentimes genetically
incompetent embryo won't implant or will
result in an early miscarriage so when
you're going through all of this you
just want to kind of you know control
for as many factors as possible and then
we also did the ni PT which is the what
does that stand for
I don't know it's basically it's early
genetic screening test it's a blood test
it's non-invasive it's not like amnio
they test for a wide range of genetic
disorders like like Down syndrome but a
wide range of other ones including some
micro deletions so we tested we did a
full panel and they all came out
perfectly normal and fine so at this
point the only thing I'm waiting for is
the 20-week Anatomy scan and we're
hoping that that will looks good five
you know ten fingers ten toes no other
you know malformations or deformations
I'm not sure what the right word is for
that but we're hoping everything looks
good and happy and unhealthy okay what
are you doing with the rest of your
embryos great question
and this is a controversial one so
please if you're pro-life don't mean but
this was not obviously an easy decision
for us IVF in general is not an easy
decision for many many reasons but
including this one this is this is not
easy but basically when you harvest your
eggs you mix them with the sperm and
then they get you know they turn into
embryos and they they grow and then you
freeze them and you really don't know
how many of those eggs are going to or
embryos are going to survive and make it
to what we call blastocyst and then you
don't know if you're gonna pts test them
how many of those embryos are actually
going to be genetically competent so you
could end up with like you could have
like 20 harvested and then end up with
like one we actually were lucky enough
to have twelve beautiful embryos frozen
or blastocyst frozen and I have seven
left if I decide to have a third baby I
don't know yet if I decide to do that
then potentially all blast through a few
more of those just trying we don't know
we could we could go through them all
but if not or if I still have some
leftovers we have decided to donate them
to science because I'm a science fine a
person this is what I'm passionate about
especially reproductive science so
that's what this was important for me
your other options are to destroy them
to donate them to another family or you
can do something that we call like a
mercy transfer which basically I know
some religious families decide to go
this route but basically what you do is
you don't take any of the drugs that you
normally would take for an IVF transfer
and so your you would implant them the
doctor would implant them in the in the
surgery room in during a time in your
cycle where you don't really have any
chance of getting pregnant everyone has
you know morals and values and different
ideas of what's going to work for them
and their family and I know people are
gonna say well why didn't you donate
them to another family in need and you
know I would love to help more families
in need who are struggling to have their
own family
but I don't know call me a bad person
but it's just the thought of having my
child my genetic child that is my
husband and me together and it's my
biological sons brother or sister out
there in the world and probably in my
city without me knowing it's just like
really unsettling to me and like really
strange and so I'm not sure I'd be able
to get past that even though I knew even
though I know it would be such a
beautiful thing to do so I have done
other things to help the infertility
community including donating to one of
my favorite charities Small Wonders it's
a toronto-based IVF charity that helps
families who are struggling to conceive
and struggling to afford artificial
reproductive technology so I'll leave a
link to them below
I basically anytime I have a party or
birthday or you know write a baby shower
or anything like that I've always had my
friends and family donate that rather
than to give me any gifts because they
just think I don't need more stuff and
if it could help somebody else what a
beautiful thing okay let's move on okay
but on that note please keep the
comments clean and respectful and kind
we all you know make different choices
in our life and yeah that's all I'm
gonna say about that
next question did you ever consider
adoption another tough one so of course
I mean I think adoption is a beautiful
beautiful option but I don't think that
it's necessarily easier than IVF I think
a lot of people like in the comments of
my my my pregnancy announcement kind of
said that like oh why would you put
yourself through all this trouble and
spend all this money when adoption is
easier I don't think it's actually
easier there's I know a lot of people
who've gone the adoption route it can
take months if not years it can take a
lot of heartbreak a lot of frustration
in the system it's it's not simple but
of course if I was unable to conceive my
own biological children either via my
own body or through surrogacy then
absolutely I would go down that path I
think it's a wonderful gift
and I really really really do have so
much respect for parents and couples and
individuals who who pursue that route
it's so beautiful
okay next question how did you deal with
social situations and determining
whether or not you tell people even
before the second trimester really
really good question so personally I was
always really open I'm just I'm an open
book in general I mean I have a YouTube
channel and a blog and I am a like
online personality so it comes it just
comes with the personality and the
territory but I know I didn't come up to
you guys until twelve and a half weeks
but that was really to respect my
husband's wishes because he's a very
private person but basically any time
that I saw any of my friends I just told
them straight up and and most of my
friends knew about the miscarriages
throughout the year
most of them knew what I that I was
going through the IVF process again even
if they maybe didn't ask very specific
questions yeah I was just always very
open about it and if I were to have told
someone and then maybe miscarried like a
week later I wouldn't have thought oh I
shouldn't have told somebody so early
how stupid of me I would have thought
okay you know this is a really good
opportunity for us to talk more about
miscarriage which is so common and yet
nobody talks about it and also an
opportunity for me to get the support
that I need from the people that I care
about in my life I know that this is
like a really personal decision and a
lot of people just feel so anxious about
telling anyone and don't want to tell
anyone until they're you know well into
the second trimester and I get it this
is this is just based on my personality
and what works for me and what my needs
are and the fact that I just feel
happier and more supported when I'm able
to talk to people about my problems
rather than just like shut them down and
move on I'm a sharer
I mean what can I say okay next question
okay so how did you deal with the
thought of potentially not being able to
carry your own baby okay
to go through surrogacy also really
great question and I mean it was really
a hard pill to swallow at first I am
arguably as you probably have figured
out a very perfectionist type-a
personality I like to control situations
and I have a feeling like a lot of you
guys who watch me probably are the same
kind of personality type so the thought
of having somebody you know several
hours away via flight god-knows-where
being carrying and taking care of the
most important thing in the world to me
without me being able to be there and
micromanage and oversee the entire
process and situation and take care of
things the same way that mace maybe I
would take care of myself and and my
health and my body oh that really really
really freaked me out so I was having a
hard time coming to terms with it it
really felt like a huge huge loss to me
so of course I was I was devastated at
just the thought of going down that
route even though I was preparing myself
for it
but I guess this sounds weird but I
really just tried to focus on the kind
of trivial positives in that scenario
mainly that like one of the kind of
things that I came up with was that like
well if I don't give birth to the baby I
probably won't be able to breastfeed
which a another major loss for me but it
will mean maybe the surrogate will pump
for me and pump breast milk for my baby
and I again I know that sounds like a
horrible positive but I wasn't able to
breastfeed my son and I have a huge
amount of guilt and shame and sadness
around that I had to exclusive I had to
I mean I chose to exclusively pump for
over a year and for any of you moms out
there who have pumped breast milk
especially exclusively you know how hard
this is it's completely all-consuming it
really took over my life and I
completely lost touch I felt like I lost
touch with who I am and my
my social life and just my ability to to
be my myself in my own body so it was a
real struggle for me that whole
experience of breastfeeding and pumping
was really traumatizing for me and I
remember the day that I stopped pumping
for my son which was just after one year
and I was already dreading starting up
again with baby number two so that from
me in my head was like I guess this tiny
little my new positive or benefit that
and like I guess like I wouldn't have to
recover from labor after you know or
from pregnancy afterwards like these are
such trivial benefits in comparison to
what I felt like I was losing out on
obviously but it just felt like all I
could really hold onto to help convince
myself that maybe this process wouldn't
be so terribly hard for me now if any of
you out there have gone the surrogacy
route or our surrogates yourselves first
of all kudos to you I mean I have such
respect for women who you know how
selfless are you to put your body out
there to help another family that is
such a beautiful gift you can give
another family so thank you for your
service but yes if you've been through
this process I would love to hear your
experience on this I know people who
have gone this route and and really
thought it was amazing so I'm sure it's
just a personality thing and the fact
that I'm like a control freak but yeah
I'd love to hear your input and thoughts
as well okay so next question
how do you continue on after multiple
losses and miscarriages and not be
terrified for your next pregnancy so
that's a really good question I don't
think you'll ever not be terrified
parenting and and motherhood is
terrifying and even when the kid is out
the worrying doesn't stop right it's
just the beginning there's there's gonna
be a whole lifetime of issues to worry
about as your child grows up this is
just step one and yes it's a very scary
step of course it's the beginning you
want the beginning to go well but yeah I
think you just have to
take it day-by-day and celebrate like
those little victories like getting you
know another another day getting to that
next ultrasound getting another week
ahead you know getting that Anatomy scan
or the prenatal screening so just taking
it one step at a time as for how did I
continue honestly there wasn't really
anything specific that I did other than
just having faith that the right baby
was going to come at the right time for
my family and that everything really
happens for a reason I know with you
know my son and and before he was
conceived we had a chemical pregnancy
and I was totally crushed but in
retrospect I look back and I feel
grateful because I really do feel like I
got the legit best child for me and my
family I think he's I mean I think
everyone thinks that their child but I
do feel like that thank god this is the
this is the baby that I got and I can't
really imagine it any other way so of
course with this round of cycles it was
more challenging because we had
back-to-back disappointments that we had
to endure but I think just kind of
reminding myself of how amazing my first
rainbow was and that good things are
really just kind of like worth waiting
for now I am also like not very
religious though I feel a lot of people
use and and and and lean on religion and
their religion to help them get through
some of these hard times but what I'm
gonna say is gonna sound really super
silly to probably most people but there
is this movie that I used to watch when
I was a little kid I haven't seen in
like 25 years it's called I think so
like the blue bird with Shirley Temple
like it's literally from 1940 Shirley
Temple folks she was just a tiny tot so
sweet but I loved Shirley Temple when I
was a kid not just the cool drink that
the non-alcoholic drink that we used to
get from like Swiss Chalet but also all
of her movies so in this movie there is
this like scene where they call like the
land of the unborn children or something
and it's kind of like heaven and there's
all these kids in this like you know
ethereal place waiting to be born
and they have their siblings and they're
all holding hands like waiting who's
gonna get called today and in like one
scene like one of the kids gets called
and gets like ripped away basically from
their sibling and it's like
heartbreaking to watch like I'm just I
literally haven't watched this in 25
years and I feel like very emotional
just thinking about that scene but
sometimes I think about that and I think
you know maybe there's a child somewhere
just waiting to be reunited with my son
and with me and and my husband and asked
as a family and even if I wasn't meant
to have another biological child for
whatever reason but I still felt like
our family was incomplete I am sure
there was a there would be a child out
there an adopted child who also would be
you know waiting to be reunited with my
my my son and my husband and I so yeah
that was like a long weird super weird
answer to a relatively simple question
but I guess like even without religion
being a huge part of my life I just
reminded myself that that embryo that
embryo that didn't work out for us it
was just not the right one for my son it
wasn't it wasn't good enough for my son
and you know he deserved a special
sibling whoever that was and it was
worth the trial and error to get it
perfect for him so I don't know that was
maybe my thinking maybe that works for
you as well as as you go through this
process okay well I think that's all I
got for you guys right now but stay
tuned in like a week or two I will put
out the part two of this vlog where I
will talk specifically about pregnancy
about this baby and this pregnancy and
other kind of juicy little tidbits and
of course if you have any more questions
whether regards whether it is related to
my pregnancy or IVF infertility anything
like that anything I've talked about if
you want me to go into more detail leave
me a comment below do not forget to
subscribe
push the little Bell button so that you
do not miss out on notifications give
this the thumbs up share with your
friends
and I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]